la passage rue d'orchies chanteur du
groupe les hôtesses d'hilaire leamy vie
certains les connaissent déjà d'autres
ignorent encore leur existence
chose certaine si vous les croisez vous
vous en rappellerez
la carnoy
mouais
on a moins
cappoen
les hôtesses d'hilaire célèbrent leur
dixième anniversaire
l'expert
la formation avec son chanteur
flamboyant et théâtrale gagne en
popularité chaque année en 2018 ils ont
présenté un opéra rock déjanté à
guichets fermés
je compte encore nés les cinq nommées
mon âge avait fait qu'est-ce que le
monde l'entende on a je souhaite comme
j'espère que le monde embarque toujours
fait des choses qu'on aime jouer à saint
jean baptiste
le groupe puise son inspiration du
compte des années 70 de doren frank
zappa mais aussi de son coin de pays et
de la maison dit leur père de serge leur
lieu de création
ce que moi la péninsule acadienne ça
m'inspire il ya beaucoup de coups de
personnages ses quatre albums y dix ans
plus tard leur marque de commerce il
toujours la même
l'humour noir le sarcasme et les
ambitions ne manquent pas benj en mls la
liste d'appels pour remplacer singa
lippi n'a pas fini de parler on n'a pas
fini non sans parent d'ado fois comme
moi on a encore des chansons à écrire
des choses à dire qu'il y est pourquoi
pas lens le porte parole
réaliser un film maintenance dans l'âme
on espère que fait des démarches mans
vers diamant cher et les atteint moins
une basse et se construit que meziane a
dedans je pense que ça
du rock punk iconoclaste au cinéma qui
sait mais il espère avoir plus d'être
des gouvernements soit qu'il ya un coup
vraiment - qui met en place une réelle
politique culturelle financièrement
sport wiam d'ailleurs servi de la
musique
cc c'est un pour quelqu'un qui avait pas
de ce qu'ils en pensaient quand est ce
que tu peux avoir des albums que cela ne
tienne dix ans plus tard le carnet de
bord des hôtesses d'hilaire toujours en
plus projet ici il y à céret radio
canada tracadie
[Musique]